get off your phone Greg Monette
yeah way to go mone Abita alright top
trending five most haunted children's
toys ever made let's pull this closer to
make this a little spooky have you seen
Annabelle I've seen the trailer for
Annabelle and it was not that scary
I heard the movie kind of sucked I heard
the movie wasn't scary watch the
conjuring I've seen the contract wait I
wanna remove yes I love scary I've seen
uh lights out yet
yeah Wow I'm not even even heard of it
no I'm afraid of the dark so what have
you seen Blair Witch yes not a new one
the new one is it object wait uh yeah
like no I know yeah the new ones that
Wow to conversation alright top-trending
let's see what you got creepy that looks
like great water it's magical
Holland's marijuana in the late 1800s a
supernatural event struck the home of
six year old Robert Otto in Key West
Florida I the son of wealthy business
owners was considered a nuisance to the
family servants one of those servants
who practice black magic cursed a doll
and gave it to Robert claiming he did
not take care of it the doll would haunt
his mother for the rest of her life
Robert took to the doll as though it
were his own brother eventually becoming
inseparable for fear of what it could do
to his family while I those mother
claimed the curse absurd the other
servants of the household claimed the
doll was bewitching Robert on a chilly
stormy evening a butler found Robert
hanging upside-down from a rafter
reciting a demonic chant with his eyes
closed on the floor below the doll
watched lying on its back
the butler pulled Robert down from the
rafter but upon getting closer noticed
Roberts mouth was not open and he could
not have been doing the chanting the
next few months some more instances of
the doll moving and speaking on its own
with Robert growing so terrified of it
he attempted to bury it in the backyard
the doll now sits in a museum in Key
West and will curse anyone who
photographs it without its permission
film the conjurer heroism of her own
perhaps no haunted toy is as well known
as Annabelle discovered in a local
thrift shop the doll was purchased and
given to a college aged woman named
Donna and her roommate who soon became
witness to unexplainable events they
would often come home and find the doll
had moved rooms and soon they discovered
childlike writings being scrawled all
over the walls after taking it to a
psychic they were told the doll was
possessed by a dead girl named Annabelle
and the girl wished to be friends with
Donna seeing nothing wrong with this the
girl kept Annabelle in the apartment
until she viciously attacked one of her
friends famed ghost hunters ed and
Lorraine Warren investigated the doll
and discovered it was actually possessed
by a demon which sought to grow in power
and possess a human neck
the warnings took the doll home with
them and walked it in their Museum now I
don't need to watch the movie
Australian Carrie Walton was determined
not to let a childhood fear ruin his
life
as an adult he returned to the house
that terrified him as a kid and found
the marionette doll trapped under the
porch he took it home and began
experiencing terrifying events at night
I would wake up to hear whispering right
next to his ear out nothing was ever
close by
he soon suspected the doll to be the
origin of the voice and attempted to
lock it up one night but as Walton
attempted to sleep
he heard wild banging and the demonic
screaming of the doll shouting let me
out the doll is believed to be the
product of a Romanian gypsy 200 years
before Walton discovered it and the toys
real human hair is thought to be the
reason the doll is possessed real human
hair
a popular fifth the state of Kentucky is
that the lucky dream doll an
eight-year-old girl named Angie Mays
stumbled upon an old graveyard with nine
hidden tombstones in the woods just
beyond her family's farm
her father told her the graves likely
belonged to children of a family who
died years earlier as the graves were
too close together to belong to adults
that night Angie was visited by a spirit
named Bucky in her dreams Bucky told her
to make a doll for each dead child so
they could finally be at peace
the follow mice and she attempted to
make a doll for the first dead child out
of some of her own baby clothes before
finishing the other eight dolls however
the maze family began witnessing strange
events they would catch the shadow of
the doll moving when the doll didn't and
found strange messages written on the
kitchen table every morning a horrifying
discovery because Angie herself and her
mother could not read or write Angie's
father fuss about destroy the doll and
upon its burning they heard demonic
shrieking legend has it that the demon
known as luck travels from dream to
dream trying to convince children to
make a doll for it to manipulate so it
can eventually possess the child's body
she's so lucky she's a star modern
hunting homes from Galveston Texas when
a mortgage
carol game aside was home curious across
the haunted boo doo doll from ebay she
soon found herself the owner of a
violent attacking and demonic possession
that she attempted to destroy numerous
times but after failing at burning
shredding and burying it she learned the
only way to get rid of it would be for
someone else to willingly take it Carol
put it back online for new buyers and
the doll was sold packaged and delivered
three times but every time the new buyer
received the package they would find
they were only sent an empty box the
doll would appear in Carol's bed night
after night even after she is over the
mail she finally rid herself of the
nightmare by giving it to a paranormal
investigator who still owns the zombie
voodoo doll to this day no I mean it
more chills whoa based on true stories
ya know these are all made up and we
just watch the pointless video I believe
it no these are supposedly true stories
especially the pondering what does I saw
movie America no I saw movie and then
I'm research oh did your fascinate you
googled it mmm and then the rain fasten
Google is the best research form you
could ever do good vision
good job to this little boy hanging
upside down chant chanting but not we've
all been there though we've all been
there I see Jess constantly anytime I go
over to help them film she's just
hanging upside down well no that's big
that wakes up that girl and that's out
that girl came they said that the the
that there was a chant going on but the
boys mouth was closed the whole time how
they get rid of the doll it's in a
museum now you need y'all's permission
to take a photo of it yeah I want to I
want to just test that out how do you
get permission from how do you get the
doll to tell you yeah
yeah thumbs up have been pretty cool to
get a picture of that doll do a selfie
one dull day to the museum like the
other ones kept coming back that's true
that should move that one kept coming
back I mean you guys have any haunted
dolls we're like and every experience
that you ever had a Furby uh yeah
actually I did I had one Furby those are
haunted I had that one shows up in my
bathroom every morning but that's normal
I'm talking about the doll right yep the
Furby okay sorry I thought pervy could
be another name for that yeah they're
like thing girl you saw the Annabelle
movie is that what happens like is this
the plot of the Annabelle movie kind of
Ellen the conjuring no but I mean like
with the girls like living in their dorm
and then they'd all attack them it's not
I guess I remember in the contrary they
had the beginning there was a thing with
the girls yeah I am wow wow you two got
something to worry about
I just got you guys a bra so right now
to never buy dolls for each other
bad I hated dolls when I was a kid my
dad tried to bring home Barbies for me
once and I was like no well I think he
sees that not my thing dad yeah I felt
that way about my Barbies - yeah yeah
yeah my Barbies are constantly haunted
and freaky you know eyes are weird you
know I used to imagine you guys ever
seen Indian in the cup board this is
true yes it's true being in the cupboard
I say cut board yes I used to imagine
having like a Barbie this is crazy
six-year-old boy fantasy and then having
the cupboard bringing it to life and I
would shrink and I would date the Barbie
and make love of the Barbie and then
when I was done with the Barbie I would
just purr back into a dog
hahaha did you guys grow up religious at
all yes or no what religion em
Catholicism Commission death Allah Aslam
[ __ ] religious at all when I was young
I'd try being like a devoted Catholic
which is really hard in America to do
when I hear stuff about demons and stuff
even though I don't really believe in
that stuff today when I hear it now I'm
like I said part of me still really does
believe that is definitely possible to
hell even yeah so you believe in yeah
but you're not religious but a believe
demons are real you believe God is real
I believe there's evil even eat all yeah
what is it
Hey yeah it's devilish yeah I believe
there's a higher power so what happens
if a demon comes after you how are you
how are you gonna argue and defeat the
demon if the demon comes after you ask
it how its day is if you can take a
photo asking you think of an answer yeah
wait just pause pause this um this uh
what's it called video possession no I'm
talking with even still how is she still
doing her bit haha this guy why did he
take it out from under the house because
man you can't just have a doll showing
underneath your house
no it wasn't underneath his house it was
underneath his childhood home yeah he
looked really stressed out in this photo
that's the definition of a stressed out
guy God God what do I do
should I shave today I don't think so
mm-hmm that would be cool to have a doll
real human hair like to get like a Tom
Cruise action figure but I like Tom
Cruise's hair on it how cool would that
be you know how much the girls would pay
for one direction dolls with real hair
rule we got business ideas ladies let's
do it we know what we're doing a top
trending you're an inspirational video
right
I felt sorry for this demon actually for
the fourth family when they were riding
on the on the table like Satan is a
murderer kill it's apparently the
daughter and the mom can't even read so
it's like that's scary the demon can't
haunt them
if they can't even read with her with a
demon saying it's like the demos failing
I wouldn't wants to do that it was
really yeah all I can do is write in
Gerasa but they don't know 100 they
can't understand what I'm trying to do
so how can I scare this this is big
benefit to not being able to read I'm
one of the few out there who can't read
and I I really know what I'm doing
granny
that's why do reaction videos this one
freaked me out though that's what
actually yeah yeah the last one how she
kept sending it and the doll just kept
appearing that would be a cool movie
actually that would be a really like you
just can't get rid of this doll that
keeps appearing see you can't trust what
you buy on eBay lesson learned lesson
learned Craigslist - and Amazon don't
trust them they're trying to get
suspicious
absolutely cause unless his prime plus
um the doll didn't seem to do anything
evil what if the doll was just wanted a
friend what if it was like just wanted
to snuggle and spoon and stuff in bed
exactly
you guys seen Toy Story what if it was
like one of Andy's toys you
yeah and Jesse oh yeah like with Jesse
when shameful she got put under the bed
for so long Jesus wanted attention no I
did Toy Story film theory that might
have been Andy's mom nassau whole video
about really yeah facts more theories
embarrass this doll didn't seem to do
anything like evil to her so he the doll
i would have kept the doll round i want
to try to understand what the doll
wanted I would have done it'll cover
thing and made love with the doll
whatever it took to get this doll to
communicate to me I would have done it
that's a good sign it's a good sign
that's a good sign I don't believe in
symbolism for the warnings of danger I
just ignore things like that all right
top training subscribe to them too and
while you're at it subscribe to me and
then when you're at that subscribe to
them
just keep subscribing you can't get
enough subscription services but now I
have very similar content to this
channel it's very banking more on baking
horrifying they bake delicious goods
I've been in a couple of videos they
have some other charming guests on there
none of them are as charming as me I
think I'm the most charming guy they've
had anger oral - I want to shout out
Yusef Ashraf to constantly comments all
the time and Yusef dude can you guys
just say his name because he loves it
when a girl says his name you said all
right now say it a little bit more
sensual we just watched a horrible video
you see when we talk to real scary oh ok
I'll seduce you right now